Привіт, любі п'ятикласники!
За розкладом урок української
мови і з вами я, пані Юлія.
Тема сьогоднішнього уроку:
“Словосполучення. Відмінність
словосполучення від слова й речення.
Головне й залежне слово”.
Поруч із нами сьогодні на
уроці будуть наші улюбленці -
коти, кішки та кошенята.
Разом із ними ми розпочнемо
мандрівку у світ синтаксису.
Пригадаймо, який розділ науки
про мову називаємо синтаксисом?
Що він вивчає?
Увага на екран!
Разом із синтаксисом завжди пунктуація.
Як же визначити, чи два слова
є в нас словосполученням, чи ні?
Скористаймося алгоритмом,
які пропонують автори підручника
“Українська мова” брати Заболотні.
Увага на екран!
Що ж таке словосполучення?
Словосполучення — це поєднання,
щонайменше, двох повнозначних слів,
одне з яких — головне, інше — залежне.
Головне — слово, від
якого ми ставимо питання,
і ми його позначаємо ось так:
увага на екран.
Залежне — слово, до
якого ми ставимо питання,
Наприклад: сонячний
день. День який? Сонячний.
День — це головне слово,
сонячний — залежне слово.
Нумо практикувати!
Спробуємо за цим зображенням
визначити словосполучення та з'ясувати,
яке слово є головним, а яке залежним
Кіт — головне слово. Кіт який? Пухнастий.
Гортати — головне слово. Гортати
що? Книгу. Книгу — це залежне слово.
Далі увага на екран!
увага на екран!
Слова в словосполученні
пов'язані за змістом та граматично.
За змістом ми можемо визначити
головне та залежне слово.
Наприклад, рудий кіт. Кіт - головне слово.
Кіт який? Рудий. Рудий — залежне слово.
Слова в словосполученні
також пов'язані граматично
за допомогою закінчень.
Наприклад, струнка кішка.
Закінчення -а в прикметнику
і закінчення -а в іменнику.
З домашніми улюбленцями.
Ці два слова пов'язані за
змістом, а також граматично.
В цьому словосполученні слова
пов'язані за допомогою закінченнь -іми
в прикметнику, -ями в іменнику
та за допомогою прийменника -з.
Відпочивати на
підвіконні. На - прийменник.
В цьому словосполученні слова
пов'язані завдяки прийменнику,
тобто, граматично.
Чим же відрізняються слова від
словосполучення і від речення?
На відміну від слова,
словосполучення точніше
називає предмет, ознаку, дію, явище.
На відміну від речення, словосполучення
не виражає завершену думку.
Наприклад, слово кіт. Воно одне слово.
Але який кіт? На малюнку два коти.
Словосполучення білий кіт, це
вже більш точніше. Кіт який? Білий.
Ми вже знаємо ознаку, що
цей кіт білий. Але їх двоє білих.
Кіт який? Праворуч.
Кіт праворуч — саме про
нього у нас словосполучення.
Речення.
Білі коти дивляться в різні сторони.
Речення виражає завершену думку.
І речення складається
з різних словосполучень.
Наприклад, білі коти, дивляться в сторони.
Словосполучення бувають
поширеними та непоширеними.
Непоширені словосполучення
складаються лише з двох
повнозначних слів - головного і залежного.
Наприклад, пухнасті улюбленці;
пити молоко; дивитися на кота...
Дивитися на кота - це три слова, але
повнозначні та самостійні з них тільки два
дивитися і кота
Поширене словосполучення складається
з трьох і більше повнозначних слів.
Одне й те саме слово в
поширеному словосполученні
може бути головним, тобто
від нього ставимо питання
і може бути залежним, тобто
до нього ставимо питання.
Наприклад, двоє милих кошенят.
Це складне словосполучення, поширене.
Складається з двох словосполучень.
Милих кошенят — кошенят
головне слово, милих залежне.
Двоє кошенят — словосполучення,
Тварини з сірими очима — це
поширене словосполучення
і воно складається з двох
непоширених словосполучень.
З сірими очима — очима
якими? Сірими. І тварини з очима.
Нумо практикувати!
Увага на екран!
Білий пухнастик —
непоширене словосполучення.
Кіт на гіллястому дереві — поширене.
Складається з двох словосполучень
на гіллястому дереві; кіт на дереві.
Синє небо за спиною.
Поширене словосполучення,
що складається з двох
непоширених словосполучень.
Синє небо. Небо яке? Синє.
Небо за спиною. Небо де? За спиною.
Замріяний погляд.
Непоширене словосполучення.
Дивитися на пташку.
Непоширене, лише два повнозначних слова.
Триматися кігтями за гілку.
Поширене словосполучення,
складається з двох непоширених.
Нумо конструювати!
Увага на екран!
Подивіться уважно на світлину,
де є не лише коти, а й їхні друзі,
а може вороги — собаки.
Вам потрібно створити словосполучення,
поширені та непоширені.
Зробіть це самостійно
вдома і запишіть до зошита,
розподіливши на дві колонки
— поширені і непоширені.
Варто звернути увагу на те, що не всі
поєднання двох слів є словосполученнями.
Запам'ятайте, не є
словосполученням підмет із присудком,
адже таке поєднання — це вже речення.
Наприклад, тварини бавляться.
Тварини (хто? що?) — підмет,
бавляться — присудок. Це речення.
Це речення.
Не є словосполученням поєднання
іменника/займенника із прийменником.
Загалом поєднання повнозначної
частини мови із прийменником.
Наприклад, біля кота (біля — це
прийменник), тому не є словосполученням.
Поблизу нього (поблизу — це прийменник)
теж не є словосполученням
таке поєднання слів.
До словосполучень не
належать однорідні члени речення.
Наприклад, коти й собаки, великі та малі
ці слова є однорідними членами речення.
У словосполученнях обов'язково
мають бути головне та залежне слово.
А як же ми тут визначимо
головне і залежне слово?
Хто ж тут головний
— коти чи собаки? Великі чи малі?
Тому ми вважаємо — однорідні члени речення
не належать до словосполучень.
Нумо практикувати!
Увага на екран!
Бути щасливим. Словосполучення.
Бути яким? Щасливим.
Грати й відпочивати. Не є
словосполученням. Однорідні члени речення.
Близько години. Не є словосполученням.
Слово близько в даному
випадку є прийменником.
Стояти близько. Є словосполученням.
Близько - повнозначна частина мови,
до якої можемо поставити запитання де? і
можемо визначити, що це словосполучення
Досягти успіху. Словосполучення.
Досягти чого? Успіху.
Час настав. Хто? Що?
Час що зробив? Настав.
Підмет і присудок. Це
не є словосполученням.
Любити рідних. Любити
кого? Рідних. Словосполучення.
Життя триває. Життя що
робить? Триває. Підмет і присудок.
Це речення, не словосполучення.
Брати участь. Брати що?
Участь. Словосполучення.
Активно й плідно. Не словосполучення.
Однорідні члени речення.
Знайдемо словосполучення:
натхненний завданнями,
надихатися сміхом, привітне сонце,
спекти піцу,
правильна відповідь, відпочивати вчасно.
Вивчаючи словосполучення,
ми також звертаємо увагу
на синтаксичний розбір словосполучення.
Схема синтаксичного розбору є в кожному
підручнику з української мови для 5 класу.
Я ж вам наводжу приклад схеми
з підручника братів Заболотних.
Перше, що ви повинні зробити —
Визначити головне й залежне слово.
Ми вже з вами знаємо як це робити.
Наприклад, прихилилась до шибки.
Прихилилась — головне
слово. До чого? До шибки.
Шибки — залежне слово.
Поставити питання від
головного слова до залежного.
Визначити, якими частинами мови
виражено головне і залежне слово.
Прихилилась — дієслово, шибки — іменник.
Вказати за допомогою чого здійснюється
граматичний зв'язок між словами.
За допомогою чого здійснюється зв'язок
між словами в цьому словосполученні?
В цьому словосполученні
граматичний зв'язок здійснюється
завдяки прийменнику ДО,
а також завдяки закінченню.
Нумо конструювати!
Увага на екран!
Можна змінювати форми, тобто
закінчення або, наприклад, вид у дієслів.
Вам потрібно зараз зконструювати
якомога більше словосполучень
із цими словами.
Ви можете навіть погратися
вдома, хто більше за одну хвилину
зможе скласти словосполучень.
Наприклад; рудий кіт; загорнутий
у ковдру; дивитися уважно,
добрий погляд і т.д.
Щастя бути котом — це не
словосполучення, це речення.
Бути котом — це словосполучення.
Підбиваємо підсумки.
Увага на екран!
Від головного слова до залежного
ми можемо поставити питання
І схематично зображуємо ось так
У нас ту є руде кошеня.
Кошеня яке? Руде.
Ще ми визначили, що словосполучення
бувають поширеними і непорширеними
Поширені можуть складатися з
двох, трьох та більше однозначних слів.
До словосполучень не належать:
По-перше, підмет з
присудком, бо це вже речення.
По-друге, поєднання повнозначної
частини мови з прйименником.
Найчастіше це іменник з прийменником,
або займенник з прийменником.
А також однорідні члени речення.
І на останок домашнє завдання.
Увага на екран!
До нових зустрічей! Мур!